the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu announcements for next week
for so for Monday just to really settle
expectations for what we're doing on
mondays we are doing rehearsals of
presentations you do not need to do the
demo of your game part of the rehearsal
you do need to do that the actual talk
that means we're asking for the visual
slides and e visuals you're going to use
that go through the full talk as if you
were going to do it don't try to speed
through it if it's in outline mode then
maybe you're testing the actual material
that you're going to be going through
please pay attention to all the talks
that you're listening to give them
feedback give the other teams feedback
about what they're saying we will be
here basically kind of like the voice
but without the cool chairs letting you
know what we think about your stuff yes
a great way to get a good grade for the
presentation is to listen to the
feedback and make changes so keep that
in mind just a suggestion even though
you don't have to demo your stuff it
might be a good idea just to bring the
computer you're planning absolutely and
testing hardware just to make sure that
the speed resolution works out you can
go fullscreen you don't have that google
chrome has taken over your entire screen
hit escape to this yeah yeah make sure
the game works we don't need to actually
play it for exam period time time length
for these presentations each team is
given 20 minutes um you will be timed we
will flag you once you hit 20 minutes
that's total for the entire presentation
including the demo limit the game
playing part of your of your
presentation to no more than 10 minutes
um anything more than 10 minutes we're
going to make a note of that but please
keep it under under 10 minutes it can be
a short or as long as you sure as you
like it could cover you could have
someone play the entire game you can
have someone to play just one part of
the game you will have somebody who has
not played your game before playing
game live on stage so that's also a test
of ours time for the you're the actual
slides part of your talk has to be at
least 10 minutes so 10 10 is a good is a
good suggestion five minutes of demo 15
minutes of talk is also fine as well
after you're finished with that talk
we're going to open it to Q&A from
people in the in the group in the room
and that will include us so rehearsal is
give your presentation we won't do the
QA we'll just do feedback final
presentations are the real deal it is
being recorded of course we're still
figuring out if we're going to live
stream it please invite your friends on
friday the town wednesday the 10th to
come word i'm sending out invites to a
bunch of people to get some some of our
local developer friends to come in and
talk and also some folks from our
department and from some of the other
game design classes to come and watch
attendance for those two days so
attendance for monday is going to be
normal like we've just been doing it
attendance for wednesday come in as come
in at one please let us know if you're
going to be late like email the video
game bosses list if you were going to be
late on on wednesday for the final
presentations will keep the sheet in the
back of the room so you can sign in as
you come into the come into the room
anything i'm missing from any of that
and then at the end of all the
presentations we're probably gonna end
up with about 30 minutes left of class
so you can open up your computers and
how people play your games if you like
totally not required but it tends to be
fun when we do that cool so if there's
no questions about any of that we are
going to do our last lecture we've arm
invited Shaun Baptiste from firehose
games to talk to us about community
management marketing and all sorts of
stuff and basically how do you get
people to play your games and after he's
done attendance will be back open cool
thank you very much thanks for having me
here this is great my name is jean
baptiste I'm a ten-year veteran of the
video game industry
my first job was at harmonics and now
which was you know a huge triple a sort
of deal and now i'm at a small indie
game studio right here in Cambridge that
was started by some former game lab
alumni Ethan fan and sheriff bought and
a Tonga liner I think I should price art
how I got into the industry in the first
place I don't have a tech background
whatsoever I was I came up through
theatre I was a theater major and one
thing I've realized in my years is that
there are a lot of theater majors at
video games it I think I've been
thinking about a lot I think a lot of it
is that video games are video games in
theatres are both have an interactive
element where there's a interplay
between the audience and the Creator
that film doesn't have necessarily and I
think a lot of theater people drift
towards there when they realize there's
no money to be made whatsoever in the
theater that was my that's how I made it
but so I was I was working in film and I
was working in theater and stuff and I
got sick and I just the only game i
could play was amplitude which was a
harm early harmonics title and as i was
playing and i was like oh i think people
make these like I don't think games just
happen like somebody makes them and I
realized that was I lived up on the
North Shore so it was closed and i just
started pestering harmonics to hire me
since I was closed and they kept telling
me no he'll eventually I I just got a
friend there who sort of said nice
things about me which was lovely of him
and that's got me an in QA QA I'm
hesitant to say that that's a good way
to start in the industry anymore because
I don't know if it's quite as valid QA
teams of garten smaller and the turnover
is a little bit difficult so it's not
necessarily the the entryway into the
industry that it used to be which i
think is a bit unfortunate i worked as a
QA person on the karaoke revolution
series early on and then on the guitar
hero series before I
becoming a technical artist which meant
that I wasn't a programmer or an artist
but I helped make them have less fights
with each other it was probably
something you guys are used to at this
point so uh so I did a lot of that at
learned how to animate and hook things
up but then they realized I one of the
things I was doing was so harmonics this
was I don't know how familiar you guys
are with harmonics is but uh this was
before Harmonix got bought by MTV and
was guitar hero would come out but that
was handled by redoctane and Activision
and their red octane then Activision and
we had a outside PR plays handle a lot
of the PR and mostly we just made games
and put them out there and there was no
real there wasn't as much of a
consideration for us doing PR from
inside but we realized as we wanted to
make rock band and we're moving away
from Guitar Hero that we would and kind
of owning our own destiny that we were
the ones who were going to have to talk
up our own games and kind of create
something about it so I wasn't the best
technical artist I'll be honest so they
moved to be over to over to running the
community because we from frequency and
amplitude there was a very small
community of I'm gonna say about 50 or
60 people on the harmonics freak com
forums and I was the only one willing to
talk to them pretty much in the whole
company so as part of my job is
technical artist I would for an hour
each day I would sit and talk with
people in the forums and try to manage
that community which was very very small
and very angry that there wasn't a
sequel to frequency or amplitude that
that was kind of a dead series so a lot
of my time was spent like apologizing I
guess how I would that that my big start
to community management was apologies so
I did that for I did that for a while
and when it came up that we were going
to have to start doing her own stuff I
got promoted up to create the community
management or the community development
team at at harmonics and I put that
together and that's when there was a big
change because then you know we're owned
by MTV
and they have a lot of money like a lot
of money and they put a lot of money
into advertising for the game and
sending us around to like every event
and stuff i went to the Grammys and was
like giving out rock band two more stay
in the time and weird stuff like that
and it started moving a little bit away
from just general apologizing daily
dealing with problems and more with kind
of creating a or at least sustaining a
cult of personality round the persona of
harmonics which was sort of punk rock
and kind of outside of it wasn't as much
like traditional game development
everybody there was a musician and there
was actually kind of this identity that
we could point to and kind of play that
up and make that sort of the character
of the company and that that we
definitely did that we played that up
and because because one of the things
that we'll get into that more when I
talk a little bit more about the
difference between marketing for
triple-a versus marketing for indie is a
lot of games in triple-a you're selling
the games as far as marketing goes
you're selling the games for indie what
you're doing is you're selling the
people who make the games and harmonics
was in this interesting place where even
though it was owned by MTV it worked a
lot more like an indie company so there
was once we were able to promote
ourselves we promoted the company as a
group of people like don't just buy rock
band by Harmonix buy the whole company
by what we do stick with us because
we're going to keep making cool stuff
and I can did that for a number of years
and it was crazy a flu constantly
everywhere stayed in hotels that didn't
have lice and stuff it was nice a lot a
lot of a lot of getting to do really
cool things I ended up getting sick
after that and spent a few years away
from the industry and when I came back
I've been playing so many Indian
independent games from small indie teams
you know things like you know stuff that
John blow and made or Fez or just a lot
of the games that castle crashers and
hominid those sorts of games and I
realized there was kind of a there
wasn't analogue to what I was already
doing with harmonics which was kind of
the in indie games you really do have to
sell the artist the artist you're
selling the artist you're trying to get
people to come because if you don't have
an interesting story in a way or that
you can sell to the press or two
journalists you're not going to get
anybody writing articles about you for
the most part that's just that's just
the case other the big triple-a
companies have lots and lots of money so
they can plant lots and lots of articles
and as far as indie stuff goes the only
way you can sell yourself is having a
good story that a journalist wants to
tell because if you don't have that
there's really no upside for them to
write an article about you or your game
or anything like that I know that seems
a little cynical but there it is that
that is the case so so let's see hmm so
when I went to fire hose the differences
in the market like I said was when i was
at harmonics a lot of what i did in
community management was keeping making
sure everybody was really invested in in
the product and in our in ourselves as a
team but a lot of it was also keeping
our secrets making sure that people
weren't leaking information from inside
of the company making sure playtesters
weren't leaking inside a company making
sure an unannounced project that a coder
on there didn't go in and update their
LinkedIn profile and say hey we're
working on rock band 2 or you know at
the time before we denounce rock behead
too and then there's a huge thing so a
lot of my stuff was managing what
information got out in independent games
my job is to make sure all of the
information gets out and that we are
constantly screaming for people to
notice us because there's so much
competition I mean just in just look at
the the explosion of independent games
in the past let's say five years six
years 2008 i think is really when it
really started becoming this definitive
thing that you can point that there's a
lot of people and a lot of people who
want also equally want people to pay
attention to them and there's only so
many outlets and there's only so many
places where people are going to be able
to read about it so you're really
fighting it's like it there's the sort
of bit it could very well very easily
turn into a sort of crabs in the bucket
situation just pulling everybody pulling
each other down luckily that's not
really how the NB game scene works a lot
of people are trying to push each other
up which is nice but you're still
competing with so many other people for
a limited amount of slots of articles
the one thing I've learned since I've
been at fire hose is that actually
matters very little if in the end and by
that I should say I mean that in terms
of sales of the game a big article on
kotaku isn't going to sell your game not
anymore when I first started in the
industry that absolutely was the case a
big article on gamespot or IGN one of
the big one the big one up at the time
that would put you over that could put
that could definitely help put you over
but for but at this point that's just
simply not the case and even a year ago
I was saying that and that everybody
should probably put more of their
marketing time towards getting YouTube
people to cover their games and now
that's sort of the predominant theory
but I think that's going the way too
because everybody who likes games has a
youtube channel and does let's plays so
even that in a way it's sort of a
reflection of what indie is doing at the
same time is now that there's just so
many people if the market sort of
flooded the novelty has worn off so it
certainly can help but there's it's
something you have to be careful to you
can't put all of your eggs in one basket
but with indie too so when I was at
harmonics there was you know I I ran a
team of I think at our height 12 people
so that was 12 people doing just
community management and just doing
public relations at fire hose I do that
all of it and and i'm also a designer
so it's like a part of my overall job
and I'm the only one doing it so I have
to choose what we do far more carefully
and I have to do it without any money
whatsoever we're not there you know
certainly you can put money into buying
ads or doing Facebook ads or that sort
of thing but I don't think that that's
necessarily the best the best use of
your time all the time and a lot of
companies don't have the budget beyond
their salaries to actually buy these ads
so what do you do and that goes back to
a lot of that goes back to what i was
saying its community management and i
guess i should get into a little bit of
what community manages when i started
doing community management in 2007 it
wasn't a thing really i think there was
one company one video game company that
wasn't an MMO that didn't make MMOs that
actually had anything approaching a
community team and that was Bioware
right around neverwinter nights they put
together a community team of two people
I think and that was just to manage
their forums and that you know let's say
that's probably about 2002 2003 and in
that time that you really only put
together a community team if you had a
large multiplayer game generally an MMO
so at the time you know Asheron's Call
had something or Ultima Online had had
it but and you know early world of
warcraft and you know all had these
these community teams but a lot of that
was there was an element of promotion to
it there was an element of marketing to
it but it wasn't so much that it was
more customer service they were really
there to deal with problems that came up
as they went Bioware where they sort of
broke the mold a little bit was it
wasn't about that it really was about
the company having direct access to
communicate with their fans and vice
versa I once was surge half joking that
my job as a community manager was at
harmonics was Ombudsman because I felt
like I had to represent the company to
the fans and then I had to represent the
fans to the company which had to be
which involved being as honest as
possible at all times with both which is
a real difficult tightrope to walk
that's so so Oh hmm sorry about that so
with community management what you try
to do is you try to build out the people
who love your games you're trying to
make them into the people who talk about
your games online the people you're
basically creating kind of an ad hoc
Salesforce a word of mouth a way of
promoting your game because that's kind
of like if if you read an article on
kotaku do you immediately go out and buy
a game probably not you might do a
little bit more research on it you might
read out up a little bit more I might go
to metacritic and check the reviews that
sort of thing but if a friend tells you
like just a person you know is like hey
I'm checking out this game there might
be multiplayer we should check this out
you're far more likely to buy it
community management is the art of
managing word of mouth of getting you're
not you're getting people to tell their
friends the people that they know you're
getting people to tell the people who
trust them that this game is good so
those people then go on and buy it and
join your community hopefully and then
they go on until so what started for
harmonics a lot of what we did is
because and then there's a scalability
aspect to it when i did when i worked on
created the the rock band community a
community site that was 100% forms-based
we did twitter we did facebook like i
said we did tons of live events but
everything was very much based around
the forums part of that was because
Twitter hadn't happened yet or it was
just happening and not as many people
were talking about it this was yeah
early two thousand seven so everything
we did we built out this huge site we
had forums we had I think I was managing
a community at that time registered
community of about 350,000 people on the
forums which was in you know that's why
we needed a team it was big it was and
there was an aspect of customer service
you might remember the like the I don't
know how many of you guys were really
playing that at the time but when it
first came out or that there were issues
and articles with the about the issues
about the instruments you know anytime
you debut new hardware there's generally
going to be problems so there's going to
issues and that happens so what's
leading up to it it was very much like
rock bands gonna be all over to Iraq and
then as soon as like it came out and
those issues started coming up the job
just clamped down into one hundred
percent customer service all the time
just trying to manage all of that which
was something that having come from
technical art I wasn't necessarily
prepared to do but I think with any game
it is no matter who your audience is no
matter what it's very valuable to have
some sort of protocol for customer
service leading up to it that's
something I think that you can probably
you should definitely do at fire hose we
don't we don't we don't we don't have
forums we have a Facebook page we have
twitter but forms they're not what they
used to be the communities aren't forms
aren't the same as they used to be and
sometimes they're just more trouble than
they're worth to manage it could be it's
very time-consuming to stop all the spam
to get in the middle of fights and stop
people from hurting each other and we
were very hands-on we weren't you know
we weren't a website Wars like ya say
whatever you want post whatever you want
we were very you know hands-on about
abuse and that sort of thing at firehose
sense we don't have as big of an
audience we don't have 350,000 people
who are following what we're doing who
are registered users or you know gonna
follow everything that we say and
everything that we do and are really
hugely invested in the company or our
games so we have to find other ways one
of the things that's probably the
biggest thing I should bring this up
here is is we started up a twitch site
or a twitch channel and this was just as
the live video was and live streaming
was starting to really become a thing
this was a couple years ago we had go
home dinosaurs which you might have seen
on the scroller that was a game that we
put out last year that was coming out
and we wanted to get attention for it
and we realized we wouldn't be able to
get every YouTube video star to feature
our dumb game
that was awesome it was awesome but
about a about you know it's about
dinosaurs stealing BBQ from early
mammals it's not like you know we knew
we weren't going to get every YouTube
star to cover totalbiscuit did actually
somehow but um we realized we kind of
had to build our own community and
really kind of make our own press for it
rather than spend all of my time our our
marketing budget is my salary there's
there's not like extra stuff we're on
buying up ads and everything so we
started meeting with twitch went out to
you know like that or they actually they
came out here one of their to talk to
the about how they want to get more
indie games on there and we sort of like
struck up a relationship with people at
twitch and that got us front page
promotions so for instance every day
monday through friday from 12 to 1230 on
our page or no on twitch you will see my
big stupid face staring out at you from
the screen because we're on the front
page right in the thing and anybody who
goes to twitch is going to see our game
first that cost us absolutely zero
dollars like as far as budget goes all
that takes is my time because we talked
to them and we we try to create good
content that they are willing to that
that that also helps their brand as well
but that brings us that you can see so
far since we started up our channel 4
million people have watched it 4 million
impressions is way outside of our price
range it's just outside of our that
would be tens of thousands of dollars to
get that many people to to get an
impression of our product to get an
impression of fire hose to get an
impression of our games to get
impression of the people who worked
there it would take that long and part
of the way as we do is like I said every
day Monday through Friday 12 to 1230 I
put on a show it's about let's quit
that's actually my game I should mention
fire hose is we have three games going
right now
three games that are served we we also
do outside projects we take on contract
work we're doing right now we're working
on a project with DARPA that's pretty
cool that actually teaches people not to
shoot people it's pretty fun but we all
but we have three eventually
commercially available products that
we're working on right now one is let's
quit that's a game i'm designing that's
a comedic debating game that that's what
I do on the show monday through friday
12 to 1230 we just i invite local
comedians in and we just talk about
different aspects of comedy while
playing the game and that has actually
been wildly successful you know we had a
Jackie Kashian who's a very big touring
comedian who I'm a huge fan of she came
in on the show and on that show I think
over the course of that one half hour we
had something I want to say it was
24,000 people which is great like I said
I would not be able to pay for that I
would not be able to afford that but
this is that this but all it takes is my
time we also have three other shows that
we do so there's the monday show that's
that's two and a half hours out of the
week and then we have a Tuesday show in
the afternoon from four to five that's
one of the other games that work on
that's a Christian who's a local
developer he's working on a game called
cat lateral damage that you may have
heard of cat lateral damage is it's
really really rad you're basically a
you're a cat it has first person shooter
controls your family's left the house
for a little while so you have a limited
amount of time to just destroy all of
their stuff and it's great you're just
bouncing around knocking things on the
floor you get points for destroying
people's monitors it's great exactly
what cats do it's very very fun and
chris is this lovely guy who's just very
he's just he loves cats he's just hit
like you know in a way that's sort of
like very honest there's nothing ironic
about it and he's kind of the perfect
person to host a show about making a
game about cats so we gave him this spot
for 25 we're all he does is he sits
there with unit
open and he shows what he's been working
on that week and and he tells people
like we do this we do this oh i just
added in these things this is how i did
that in unity so it's one part
demonstration of his game and one part
tutorial and that brings in people to
people who want to learn more about
making video games as well as people who
are just interested in a game about cats
knocking your stuff over that's you know
that and that that really works form and
it really fits the theme of this game
the other game we have is a game called
20xx which we just announced two weeks
ago if you are a fan of games like Mega
Man X or you know those sorts of
platformers it's a game very much
similar to that we're working with a
team out of out of believe Maryland
where they where they currently reside
so part of that is we I should mention
that should clarify that fire hose games
last year late last year we became as
opposed to just a studio we became sort
of we opened up an incubator for
independent games so local for the most
part local indie game developers who
have good games that they really want to
work on could come to fire hose get a
monthly stipend get office space and
then and we'll help them with the
development of the game will help them
with the promotion of the game we help
them with kind of everything and sort of
just it's more like a partnership and
internally in both cat lateral damage
and 20xx are part of that program and
and and it's great working because
that's like cat lateral damage and 20xx
and let's quit our three incredibly
different games like I said 20xx has a
very sort of Megaman X feel it's very
hardcore it's very platformer e-cat
lateral damages about cats so that have
that has a completely different audience
I'm sure they're you know in a Venn
diagram there's some crossover and then
but let and then let's quit is just a
game where you write words down like you
right tweets and then you try to be
funnier than other people the three
games have almost no shared audience
across them so we have to approach
everything very very differently I think
showing let's quit but actually showing
comedians playing it that helps because
that actually plays into the
Meredith of the game the fiction of the
game which is allowing you to be funny
and then we have comedians come in and
kind of vote on whether you're funny or
not and there's a there's a that's
creating sort of a cult of personality
and at the same time they're also
meeting the creator's so like I said
earlier when I was talking about how
people pushing their own the pushing the
artist as opposed to the art we sort of
play into that a little bit having Chris
Cheung come in and just show development
on think it's so earnest if you get a
chance you should really watch it
because he's just the most like likeable
smart dude he's just going through in it
and I mean for show for a for a live
stream where you're just where he just
basically has unity open and he's just
moving things around he it's like
several thousand people over the the
hour watching him which is nuts but it's
great people love it with 20xx we've
just started i'm just working on the
marketing plan for that and marketing
map for the next six months or so and
that's just they should they should say
that's when i'm just planning out this
month these are the things we need to
talk to this is we need this many
screenshots we need to have a trailer
for februari we need to have this and
you just oh like just coming up with
those milestones in the same way that
i'm sure you come up with your
milestones for your project we're doing
the same thing but on the marketing in
these are the goals we need to hit in
december these are the people we need to
talk to in january if we can get an
exclusive for februari that means we're
going to need to be talking about in
december and have a pitch for that have
some sort of you know powerpoint
presentation or just a really good email
with good resource screenshots and
videos and stuff that we can send out to
different outlets to try to get a little
bit of coverage because you still like
even though i said that articles don't
have a direct effect on sales they do
have a direct effect on zeitgeist i
guess i should say so there is a sort of
cultural cachet that comes from being
having a big article on your games about
there but it doesn't necessarily
translate to sales but if you know how
to use it
and you know take advantage of that
cultural cachet you can bring more
people in which I I find useful but
these games are every single one of
these games I have to market differently
because it marketed to different people
I said 20xx also that that games you
know it's a it's going to be on steam
it's I think was at 1499 and that game
we put out in early access that's a one
of the early ways we're trying to market
it is getting it out on early access and
getting people who are excited about
mega man style platformers really
talking about that game and very excited
about that game where is with let's quit
that's just going out to comedy fans all
I'm doing is talking to comedians for
the most part because comedians if they
like the game they're going to tweet
about the game and turns out comedians
have lots of fans who like comedy who
would have thought that with cat lateral
damage as far as I could tell the
audience for that game is every person
on earth it involves cats it involves
mindless destruction it's everything the
world is asking for right now it's just
it's beautiful ed I love Chris and I
love the game it's amazing and that that
also takes that sense in a way that's a
little bit more of a mainstream game
that also takes a completely different
approach because we're not selling that
game too hardcore gamers hardcore gamers
are certainly involved invited but there
but like this is a game that I can give
to my mom or I could give to like a
friend who just already likes video
games and both could get something out
of that and that takes a different
approach because you don't want to come
up with a like I wouldn't want to come
up with an ad or a promo for the game
that was like you know like like this is
the baddest game ever it's going to
destroy your life like it's not going to
we're not going to it's not i'm not
going to be advertising that way because
that'll turn off the people who are not
hardcore gamers they're they're not
going to want to play something that you
know acts like it's going to destroy
them where's also if you go too soft on
the other side that's going to turn off
other people so you're going to find a
sort of a Midway line between that and
that's another thing I'm working on
right now with Chris but for as far as
video goes on Twitch I think that's very
very helpful I should probably start
getting ready to take questions I think
think about it but um I didn't I guess
I'll one thinks you asked me to was
about a I GF and the IndieCade for me
for it's a hard thing because I do
certainly find value in marketing for
like as far as like award shows and
stuff like the IGF getting Awards I
personally have a whole lot of problems
with the whole Howard's for any art I
just I guess I think I just had personal
problems with it's just I think it's
very very valuable and I think for
especially for young developers who are
trying to get their name out there
getting your game into as many festivals
as possible is great don't break the
bank doing so a lot of them require
submission fees so if you can find
festivals that fit the genre of the game
just do your research know what you're
submitting to if like I GF has something
like 7,000 people submitting every year
and that cost and that costs money for
you to submit so if you really if you
think you can compete definitely do it
otherwise put your efforts into a
different festival Wiccans which can
still get you like a little you know a
little you could win something and then
you can put that on everything that you
mark at the game with like a winner of
the nineteen eighty nine nine I don't
know why what with 1982 I'm old so yeah
you just put that award on there I'm
sure you've been on Steam and you've
seen the just they have like in a
section where you can actually just put
links to every award you've got and then
it shows up and there's a little graphic
that's really good and that can get your
name out there and even though i have a
problem we'll see the value in it
IndieCade is one of the funnest things
I've ever been to and every time I get
really down on this industry which
happens going to indicate makes me
remember why I love working with the
people I love I love this industry and i
love the
your crap that people come up with
because it's a great place for games
that were completely outside the
mainstream to exist and live like one
that's how I found out about this game
last year called a dominique pomplamoose
I don't know if any of you have played
it yeah it's just this it's a musical
it's an opera game which is adventure
singing it's nuts and it's great and it
but there's how are people never would
have found out about it if it weren't
for just like winning the IGF awards for
noticing weirder games that are outside
of the mainstream like that but yeah I
think I should open things up for
questions if anybody has anything
specific yeah I think there's probably
still some value for triple-a and part
of that is because Triple A there's you
know the one thing that's great about
being a triple a developer is you have
resources and lots and lots of resources
so one of the things we would do went
you know any time you talk about launch
of a game it's be like ok so let's say
Assassin's Creed the next one supposed
to come out on sep tember ninth of 2015
you want to own that news day and that
means you're planting articles 4 sep
tember eighth and sep tember 9th at
every outlet in the world so that that
day when every person who checks video
game blogs reads a video game blog the
only thing they're going to be reading
about is your game it's basically like
playing a commercial on a loop for an
entire day until you've subliminally
made that person by your game that's
sort of the whole idea independent we
cannot own a news day it's very
difficult because it is it's expensive
and time-consuming
really really time consuming to own a
Newsday as an independent because just
just planting one like major article in
a big thing like a cut say a cover
article for Game Informer that's so many
man-hours between the person who's
negotiating that deal and making it
happen coming up with the story that's
sort of that you're tried like the
narrative for the game that you're
trying to sell Plus also art resources
like getting your artists to deliver a
whole bunch of screenshots but also you
know photo shops of the all the
characters so we can all that's so
expensive in time and money and Indies
can't do that so I think for us we can
get articles but really getting an
article in everything simultaneously on
the same day I it's the funniest thing
that ever I've is like when get go home
dinosaurs came out I was sending review
codes out to things and I was like so we
have an embargo for this and one
reporter literally wrote back hahaha we
don't have that we do not have we don't
have the muscle to like be like you this
isn't part we can back up this embargo
triple-a places have a hard time backing
up an embargo but they have the benefit
of being like well if you don't adhere
to this embargo we're not going to give
you coverage of the next game whereas an
in de pere in indy you would be cutting
your nose off like right there like well
fine you don't get to do the next game
and they'll tell you you won't have an X
game so yeah so there there's there's
like I said there's certainly cultural
cachet I think for Indies but it's more
valuable for triple-a so um are so
you're talking to a community management
as you described as a word-of-mouth deal
for all for a lot of it um do you this
part of your purview then doing bundle
sales and other types of other types of
sales where it's if you get somebody to
play the game maybe they'll talk to
somebody else about the game ya doing
bundle sales see that's another one I'm
torn on because I see the value in
bundle sales but I see that that value
is diminishing day by day there are so
many bundles out there and there are I
mean Humble Bundle being one of the
biggest but then there's like
70 other ones that you can go to and
humble bundles great to work with
because they're very protective of the
steam keys that you put out whereas a
lot of the other bundle places they
don't have as much security so what
happens is you put your thing in a
bundle it's that bundle sells 10,000 you
get 13 cents on the dollar for whatever
people paid or let probably less
probably probably much less but you
don't get that what you're not getting
that much money you're selling at a
discount to try to get a huge amount the
thing is what a lot of the people buying
those are their overseas and what
they're doing is they're not buying a
game because they're a fan of you or
your game or they want to play it or
your game was just one other thing in
the bundle they're buying up steam keys
and then they are selling them on their
own sites overseas so basically they're
buying your game for and you know 15
other games for five dollars total in
the bundle and then they're selling all
of those at half off of retail price and
that cuts into your sales so bad because
when people actually do want to play
your game by they're looking for a deal
so they end up going to this you know
off-brand site that's selling steam
codes from it and it's rough like that
that there's a lot of Indies who've shot
themselves in the foot by going to
bundle crazy and then really killing the
long tail on their sales in my opinion
yet yep
um I think a few more people found out
about it um I don't think it had not on
sales uh not much not much and even a
time that was when that was sort of
happening and he was he you know it
wasn't like the most glowing playthrough
of all time that he's ever played but he
liked it and he said it was really fun
and dumb which is what we were going for
so so yeah he liked it but it in the end
it as far as sales goes it wasn't as big
of a driver as one would think i dunno
of games that uh on that totalbiscuit is
covered that that has had a pronounced
effect on sales but their multiplayer
games their jet they're not like our
game was a it was it was single player
whereas if you have a you know a
multiplayer shooter or if you have
something like hearthstone a game where
people are playing together online
that's his audience his audience does
care about eSports and does care about
big multiplayer games and ours wasn't
that so i don't i don't know if that was
necessarily the best fit but still nice
that he liked it nicely played it oh god
yeah go ahead from
I do manage the steam forums a little
bit mostly for customer service because
that would be that would be the first
people place people would go rather than
emailing us we had a link inside the
game where people could email us if they
had problems if there was the game was
there were bugs or something like that
they were linked but a lot of people
went straight to the steam forums and
would you know talk about their problems
on there and do direct search stuff but
as far as like building up the community
there some games work for that and some
games don't I think games that are
multiplayer and just do better as far as
like steam form communities it's just
easier to grow a community like that
build a community there I think but
we're for single-player games people are
less interested in I think talking to
other people about them let maybe Skyrim
like you know that's sort of a single
player game where there's a huge
expansive world and there's more to
share and it's less linear I think there
might be more room for community on
steam yeah yes right oh yeah I think so
so events are difficult for Indies
because events by their very nature cost
money to travel to to stay at luckily
the independent community is great
because you know we'll just call up 19
other companies and be like hey you guys
go into this cool wanna get an Airbnb
and then we just share it and try to
keep costs now but it's still expensive
you can't do that for a flight or to get
places but you might be able to you
shouldn't it's just you know so so so
but I will say this if you can go to an
event if there's any conceivable ways
you can go to event and I mean just
about
the event where there's other game
developers they're talking about games
any sort of game based conference or
expo go to it absolutely go to it the
like is you know I've been talking about
word of mouth one of the best ways of
word of mouth is going out and meeting
other developers who have other
communities supporting their games
talking to them about their game you
talking about your game and just sort of
sharing because then they are going to
go in there going to probably be like
hey check out this new friend I made
he's making this game and it's pretty
cool and you're you're adding to your
getting more people noticing it and it's
better to be part of the overall game
development community than it is to be
outside of it but by the same token
sometimes you just don't want to talk to
people and that's fair to yeah oh that's
yeah I should mention that so when we
first started out like I mentioned we
did it because we wanted to sell go home
dinosaurs and another game that we had
made a port of it called slam bolt
scrappers and so we started off with
that and it became very apparent after
two weeks that we only had two games and
that's not a good show that's not a
great show so on that was our Wednesday
show that was our inaugural show on our
live stream live stream channel but
we're after those two weeks we're like
what what else can we do like we should
we shouldn't give up on this because we
don't have two games how do we build our
audience more and then we're like well
what if we played other people's games
and then we realized well what if we
bring in other developers and then they
bring in their games with them and then
we play their games while they're
standing next to us and then we just
talked about and we I have a standing
desk at work and it's just the two of us
stay there and play games the thing and
we just interview and talk to them about
the game that they made while we're
playing it and I've called that like you
know sharing create you create it you
bring your own spotlight and then you
share it and that helps we're held we
help get other smaller others because we
don't do a lot of big games it's very
rare that we did we did I think we did
super smash brothers i think is the
biggest game the biggest like mark
game that we've had on our live stream
and that's just because everybody at the
office is addicted to it but largely we
have other people in like we had in
January we had zoe quinn in we've had we
have people before that like just a
bunch of other developers throughout the
country because sometimes they couldn't
come in so we'd have them skype in we've
had it's just it and it's helped them
but it also helps us because it gives us
content for our show it helps give them
exposure and it helps build our audience
over time because they're tuning into an
exciting show and watching game
developers talk about game development
and seeing that sort of inside baseball
is for some reason exciting to people I
don't know why it's sort of it's sort of
but it's a but it but there's something
that people enjoy tuning into about it
yeah all right thank you for watching
having me that's good good luck on your
projects this week before to see him um
are you gonna be able to stick around
for a little bit or you have to run off
okay cool so if anybody wants to talk to
him mom now feel free to come on down to
talk then we're going to break for about
10 minutes come down and sign up other
thing I should know gianna is coming
today at around two thirty to talk to
some of the teams if you want to talk to
her if you have burning questions about
your game that you need to get answered
by one of our clients she's here and
available to talk to you otherwise the
rest of the class period is for yourself
the pipe